[music playing]
What we're going
to be doing now
is something that
is really dangerous.
The village has located
in Africanized bee nest.
Africanized bees are
called killer bees.
And the deal with
killer bees is they
were made by trying to
develop a super honeybee, one
that is incredibly productive.
But a side effect of that,
and unintentionally, they
wound up also making
a hyperaggressive bee.
Killer bees kill people.
The [inaudible],,
work around this.
The real genius is this chunk
of smoldering termite nest.
Oh, yeah.
Smoky.
We're going to
make lots of smoke.
And what the smoke does is
it messes with the bees'
chemical communication.
It basically inhibits those
bees, their pheromone, that
tells the whole hive to attack.
Oh, yeah that's red.
[inaudible] After a
scramble through the jungle,
we reach the nest.
[inaudible]
Yes.
Alan is busy
chopping away, getting
at the center of the hive.
This is a hollowed out log.
And they're living right
in the middle of it.
Wild honey provides a vital
source of sweet energy.
The [inaudible] are careful
to leave the hive intact.
And they take only
what they need.
We've got to work fast before
we run out of light and smoke.
I'm just working like crazy.
I got to keep blowing
smoke into this hole,
or they're all going to
come out by the thousands.
I'm tired.
OK.
I'm coming.
Yeah.
Here you go.
One's stinging my leg right now.
The bees are getting angry.
If they swarm, we're in
deadly serious trouble.
I need to speed this up.
Oh.
They're coming out.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Look at this.
There's the hive.
Here it is.
There it is.
It's a huge, huge colony.
If they have enough honey in
there, they can recuperate.
Ow.
They're stinging
the-- [inaudible]..
OK, keep chopping.
They are stinging me.
Ow.
Our killer bee honey heist
is at a critical stage.
If it takes much longer,
the bees will attack.
We're running out of fire.
We're running out of smoke.
Got it.
OK, we found the
honey, the mother lode.
It's so much honey.
All right.
Let's get out of here.
Let's move.
That could have
gone horribly wrong.
And I've never done that before,
ever, raided a killer bee nest.
Mmm.
That is really good.
It's definitely going to be
a hit back at the village.
[music playing]